so in this video i'll start on
set discrete time set markov chains
okay so in this on in this part i'll
first introduce
what it's like discrete time markov
chains are then i'll move into paths and
start probabilities for
such dtmcs or select discrete time sub
markov chains
then onto probabilistic it's like
reachability and then finally on to it's
like rewards and
expected a slight reachability so what
are
such discrete time it's like markov
chains well
we can think of them as
structures or transition systems
augmented with
slight probabilities so the states
these can these represent the possible
select configurations of the system
being
select modeled labeled by
atomic propositions so these are
properties that hold
in these select states and then the
transitions i model the evolution of the
system
state and here um it's in
select discrete time steps and it's like
probabilities
are the likelihood of making certain
slight transitions
slept between slept states and this is
um since we're in
a straight time model these are given by
and we have a finite
number of states these are given by
discrete probability
distributions so first just
for those that don't know a quickly
structure this is given by a finite set
of states so these are the set of states
of the system we start in some state
let's call that s
zero and then we have a transition
relation which is over the cartesian
it's like
product of the state space with itself
and
the tuple s s prime is in the transition
relation if there is a transition
in the system that goes from state s to
state
s prime and we also have a labeling
slop function that goes from states to
sets
of atomic select propositions so these
give the set of atomic propositions that
are true in a
slow state so here is an example
so here we've got that it's like initial
state that isn't
labeled by any atomic
propositions then we have a our
transition
so we have that the pair s0 s1 is in the
transition our relation and then we can
go to state
s1 which is labeled by the atomic
proposition so try so what's the
difference
so between these and such discrete time
it's like markov chains well all that
changes is that the transition
function is replaced by a transition
probability
it's like a matrix so we still get a
finite set of
states s and initial state s
0 and a labeling
select function going from states to
sets of
atomic propositions but now we have a
transition probability select matrix
which given any pair of
our states so it returns eight it's like
it's a probability
except value so that's a real set number
so between
zero and it's like one
and if this gives the probability that
there is a
of making a slight slight transition
it's like between the pair of
slit states and the one slight
requirement
is for any state s if if we sum over
all of the states in s then the
probabilities
sum up to one so this
means that we require the total
probability
of making a transition from any state in
the or dtrmc is
slot one okay so here's
an example and let's go into a little
bit more
slight detail on this so this is a
model of a very simple select
communication
it's like protocol so we start in state
s
select zero after one step we make a
our transition to select probability
state s1 and this occurs with
probability one so after after after one
time step we try to send a
our message and with it's like
probability
0.1 the channel isn't
ready so we just wait in state s
looks like one so we've got this self
loop here with
so probability 0.85 we successfully send
certain message so we move to state s3
which has the uh labeled by the
atomic proposition success
and with probability 0.05
we failed to send so we moved to this
state s2
and then in the next step we restart so
we have this
transition which happens with except
probability one where we go back
to state s 0.
so more formally for this
example we've got states s0 s1 s2 and s3
as i've said we've got the initial state
s
zero here's the probability transition
matrix so notice if we sum all of it
select the values in any looks like row
this sums
up to one and we've got the three
atomic propositions that label the
states s1 s2
and s3 so just to give you one
other example of a dtmc
here's how you can model a six-sided die
using just a fair coin so this was due
to both
it's like knuth and um yao
so here we start in s zero
and then we flip in each state we flip a
our coin
and if we flip a h then we take so the
upper branch
and if we flip a tail and we take a
our lower branch and we keep
flipping coins until we reach one of the
final states here
which is labeled by what
um face of the die of represents
okay so one question we might ask is
is this that model are correct does it
actually
is that model a it's like select die so
is it's like the probability that we end
up
in this state here for example which
just represents rolling a4
does this happen with probability one
it's like six or we could ask
do we end up in it's like one of the
end states with it's like probability
one
we might also ask how efficient
is this what's the problem what's the
probability
that we need more than four our coin
flips to reach one of the final
our states because notice that we have
these
loops here which mean which um
means that we can have an unbounded
number of steps so before we reach one
of the final
our states okay so as we'll see
uh the approaches that i
introduce will allow us to answer these
kinds of
our questions okay so let's now go on to
paths and
select probabilities for our dtmc so
this
allows us to start reason about our
behavior of a
our dtmc but we first need some
it's like probability of basics so we
need
um an experiment or
first of all we need to know what a our
sample space is so this is
it's like the possible outcomes of some
slight experiment
and we also need what is an event so
this is a
subset of um the our sample space
and then we also need so the probability
of
an event so this is the degree of
certainty that a given event will
occur so let's give a very simple slight
example
say that we toss two select coins well
what's
sample space well that's possible
outcomes
of the coins so they could both be heads
the first could be a head and
the second tail the first tail and the
second ahead
or both of them tails and one
event is at least one head
okay and what's the probability of this
will
cure there's it's like probability
one-half is that there is precisely one
head
and then there's also the case where
there are two heads so
overall we've got probability that this
at least one head is
three quarters
a second example is that we toss a coin
infinitely so often so here
so the sample so that space is the set
of all
it's like infinite so that sequences of
heads
and tails
and one such event is that we get a head
in the first three select rows so what
is
are the probability people either so we
get it the first time
or we first throw a tail and then we
throw a head
or we throw a tail then a tail and a
head and so overall
we get the probability is um
7 8. so more
i generally we get probability space
so we've got a so sample space it's like
sigma
so this is an arbitrary non non-empty
set
and then the event set
sigma is a family of subsets of the
sample
space such that it's closed under a
complementation so if some set a is in
the set
then it's like the compliment so
um is also in the um
family of subsets is also closed under
countable site union and
finally it contains
it's like the empty set so so
notice so since it contains slightly
empty set and it's closed under
it's like complementation then the
sample space
itself is also in this family of
subsets now these
are elements um these
so elements in sigma these are called
the measurable
subsets and sigma is called a sigma
algebra
on the sample space and then finally
so the probability select measure
is a function that goes from
so um the event set to
zero one such that the probability over
the
for the sample space
is like one and for any disjoint family
of
it's like measurable sets then the
probability of that
it's like union is the sum of
the probabilities okay so let's give one
simple example so i said before we go
back to the dtmcs
so let's consider
the sample space which is the set of
natural
numbers the events that could
be either um the whole set up sorry
so the empty set the odd
natural numbers the even ones and the
whole set
itself so if you look we can see that
this is closed under
complementation and obviously it's like
countable
it's like union and it also contains
it's like the empty set then we could
define
the probability select measure that
gives
probability a half odd a probability a
half
so even looking probability zero for
the empty set and probability one for
the whole set
so now let's go back to our dtmcs
so what is our sample space
going to be here so here it's going to
be the paths or
the executions of the
uh our dtmc so this
the path that represents one possible
slip behavior or execution of the
our system so so formally
it's a infinite sequence of slide states
such that for any pair of
such states in
the sequence there has to be a
transition
set between the two select states so
that means that the probability that i
can go from s
i to s i plus one is like greater than z
is greater than zero
for all i so let's give an example
execution for our simple it's like
communication it's a protocol that right
so i introduced
earlier well we first start so there's a
transition that goes from state s0 to
state s
it's like one then we wait so this is
this
uh self loop here so there's a our
transition from
s1 to s1 then we fail
so then there's a our transition from s1
to s2
then we retry so we go back from s
s2 to s1 then we start again
and this time we are succeed so then we
go from s1 to s3
and then we just stay in s3 taking this
self loop here okay
so it
our sample space is the set of paths so
we need to define a
probability space over paths
and so we need actually to have a
set to reason about other dtmc went
starting from
from some state s so we actually
for any starting state s we define a
probability space over the path starting
from this
state s so intuitively
um
so we've got the sample space is
infinite paths starting from the state s
the events are
sets of it's like infinite
infinite paths now so we start from
it's like basic
events and these are called cylinder
sets so what is the
our cylinder so given some finite path
then the cylinder equals the set of all
infinite paths that have this finite
path
as a prefix
so for example it's like the cylinder of
the path which is first state s then s1
then
s2 so we have this path here and then
it's all possible
it's like infinite paths from from here
so let's do this more formally formally
okay so we've got our our starting state
s
so and so we wanted to find so the
probability space
we'll set the sample space so so again
these are all infinite paths
starting from this state s what's the
event set well this is the least sigma
algebra
that includes all of these select
cylinders
so it includes for every
finite path it includes the
corresponding
cylinder set and then what's the
probability
of measure well this so we just
first define the probability for
other cylinders which is straightforward
it's just that the probability of a a
cylinder
is given by it's like multiplying so the
probabilities of each of
the transitions of the finite path
so for this select cylinder here it's
the probability that we make a
transition from s0 to s1
multiplied by the probability that we
make a transition from s1 to s2
so these select probabilities are
well defined and it can be shown that
there is a unique
extension of this to give um
a probability it's like measure
over the full event set
so let's just give an example okay
so here we have um for our simple
select communication step protocol let's
consider the parts
where sending fails the first time
so we go from s0 to
s um s1
and then we go to state s2 so
what's the probability of this well it's
the probability that we go from s 0 to s
1 which is one
multiplied by the probability that we go
from x 1 to s
2 which is 0.05
so the probability of this like cylinder
is
um 0.05
so let's do a second so example so these
are
let's consider the event which are paths
which so eventually um
gets the success
so that state and there's no slip
failures
so we go from s0 to s1 and then we wait
a
number of steps and then
eventually we make a our transition to
s3 so
if we think about this then these are a
set of
infinite paths of the form
s zero and zero or more s
select ones so we take this our
transition zero
or more times and then we end up in s3
and then we just stay in s3 in
definitely so
the um what is the corresponding
event well this is the disjoint
union of other cylinders where we first
we go from s0 to s1 and then
our directly to s3 or we go from s0 to
s1
we do this loop once and then we go to
s3 or we do the loop twice
or three times etcetera
so therefore what's the probability
well here it's we have it's
like the probability of um the disjoint
union of these are cylinders so since
this is a
probability select measure
this can be turned into a our sum and
then for each of these
our cylinders so we know what the our
probability is
it's just it's like multiplying
it's like the probabilities that are in
the finite path so
in the first case it's one
for this first step and then we go
straight from s1 to s3 so it's one times
0.85 it's like the second case
so we do this loop once so it's one
times 0.1
once then times 0.85 or we do it twice
and
so on we can rearrange this and we can
pull out the 0.85
and we end up with this sum here which
therefore gives us
it's 0.85 times 10 psi divided by 9
and we get that the final probability is
17
over so 18. okay so i'll stop this
this video now and in so the next one
i'll go on to probabilistic
so reachability for our dtmcs and
so rewards and expected so reachability
for
dtm cities